I guess we should bring Kevin Brennan in
seventh revenant own bread in it yeah
we're bringing Kevin into kind of
there's a lot of hostility hostility in
the room we would like some more yeah
there's something to soothe or mellow it
down a little bit so I relate Kevin we
uh we just ran late there's an argument
in studio and normally we like to shy
away from arguments in studio as you
know yeah but this time all the police
this time it was unavoidable yeah who
calls the police in New York yes there's
a murder yeah nobody's never watch Law &
Order how's your uh I was I actually did
anything to show you sir it was really
fun and now when are you on there are
you dead I did yeah what do you want how
are things with you at the compound I
guess I guess dug it you know improved
there so now suppose I'm getting two
days a week so yeah they're plugging
something for you they mentioned
something that's why I'm asking what was
the news thing you're doing just my I
was doing Monday and now I'm supposed to
be doing Monday and Wednesday so well
she's announced it on the air he didn't
he didn't announce how much I'm getting
paid or worth it he's just what any when
I was on show money goes goes and how
would you like to do another show same
amount of money right so now I'm kind of
backed into a corner kind of have to do
it yeah now now I look like a [ __ ] if I
like was like hey where's my extra show
and then I get one and I'm you know
whatever because this is what you've
been asking for the high now and I like
it and I feel like a real idiot you like
it though do you like like podcasting
brush it's fun right I love it now you
know I love it cuz there's no there's no
white women staring at me you know like
white women no no and then in the
they're just staring at you me in the
audience like just judging they they
don't go to have a good time like if
they see a black guy agree or like
another lady comic or something like
that that's fine but if they see a white
dude it looks like an off-duty cop like
me mm-hmm okay they're just ready to
[ __ ] judge you know and they they
really the slowest to break down even if
the arrests across laughing they did
they're holding out holding out you'll
find that too you notice it right like
in the all you can see they're just
holding out they're [ __ ] holding out
cuz it like well you can't set it at you
at my job I go yeah
yeah we're not at your job hunt so that
might be an issue too now I don't say
that we're about thinking it the whole
time anymore maybe they've read my mind
well your your lips cuz your mouth it
well they're laughing wait why am I in
the middle chair who's coming in you sat
down dude
is that weird sit mighty close there no
I like it here it's a weird angle
whether you want to set us a day your
seat do you or praise it you put them
down oh I like that that's perfect it'll
branding yeah do you also a problem with
white women at your comedy shows Jim you
know but I I know what he sat went on at
the cellar recently and there was like a
table of four white girls like they
don't like 20 25 not a problem but I'm
like okay and I can see them at times it
takes it's harder to get them to give in
and kind of come over and then when
everybody else is laughing a lot of
times you'll see them joining in nice
well you're right yeah hold out they
just literally hold out because they're
like this is an appropriate they just
ready to go this is in it this is
inappropriate what you're doing is
inappropriate it's really not because
I'm not I don't like I'm just doing my
act you know I might try a joke or
whatever I might do some crowd work even
when you do crowd work you know it's
like you know women want to be equal but
you can make fun of a guy in the
audience forever and if you say
something about a lady I mean that's
kind of always been but with me know
he's might like we want to be treated
equal I go well i if i insult what
you're wearing the whole crowds like oh
that's not right but you could do it to
a guy all day so it's just it's there's
there's all these double standards and
uh but white women it's not brown women
or black women it's white women who are
like who have jobs right and they're
becoming like real people you know they
go to work they hold their [ __ ]
coffee high right you ever walked out
and see them walking to work with their
I'm got coffee I'm going to do something
important you know I'm gonna set an
email you think they're showing off yeah
they're like I'm going to work I'm
marching right right and you're just
like just keep your coffee yeah I'm just
like I know you guys aren't doing the
guys aren't like we've been working for
years [ __ ] you with women working as
a new earth yeah yeah yeah and I'm not
and so they think they're like they
gotta be they just gotta be this thing
you know like
they gotta be respected and appreciated
I'm not you know you gotta earn some of
that you have to hold it high they don't
forget we hold it usually a chest level
and that's the last thing these your
tits in your coffee maybe that's what it
is their tits are cock-blocking me yeah
that could be it but ya know it's
usually young if you see 40 year old
white women I don't feel that with
anybody yeah but it's like we usually 20
to 25 they're an entitlement point I
know this entitlement or just well this
guy's gonna say something I don't like
or this is aggression or they just would
most read what you're saying a little
differently plus if you like a black
dude you can say literally whatever you
want I know it sounds racist but like
they know cuz because they see
themselves white women see themselves as
like being oppressed all these years and
they still see black people as being
oppressed you just said that white women
only started working a couple years ago
so maybe there was an impression maybe
it's not my problem no it is so the the
so so when they see a black comic go up
there they're like you know they're in
there and they're in a similar situation
that this guy's in right now so they can
they can rally behind him where no one's
gonna know and when a white comic goes
up like looking like me no one's like
rooting for me so you're just sitting
there going like you are speaking for
the voice of the people that don't get
to be heard the white male yeah I got
yeah we're tired of getting kicked out
teeth chicken all over this people think
like you like we've had it so good for
so long even [ __ ] commerce we'll go
go up and go like we've had a pretty
good run that's like the joke we've had
a pretty yeah we're not doing so good
now but we've had a pretty good run so
they make that joke we don't like that
I'll make the joke like you know I know
what's gonna tell me what to do that's
why like podcasting cuz like even when
I'm here at Sirius you gotta say good
morning to everybody that's kind of
corporate where when you do a podcast
yeah you know you don't have that you
can just like I can say the n-word
I mean I actually should I get a bonus
if I say the n-word you like compound
better than serious because it's serious
you have to say good morning compound
you say the n-word
I don't know you can't combine those
things
this is like a commercial for copy so
you know that's how that's all right
look at it just you you don't it's not
corporate at all and whatever and then
the podcasting is even is even less
corporate you know cuz it's free it's
very freeing podcast yeah you really are
who you you are communicating directly
with people due to patreon at all yeah
how is that because it's going pretty
good way patrons you get like I'm like
I'm doing better in Bobby Kelly okay
what see that's amazing thing take
somebody down with you yeah that's
alright everything's a grudge match with
me I like that so I'm at like 350 okay
Emily I've only been doing it for a
month and people like you're not doing
as good as calm down I know you [ __ ]
come town is really is it once who I
don't know if they were ahead of the
curve but Thursday well yeah they have a
lot of people yeah you're not doing as
well as come town you're like [ __ ] you
I'm doing better than Bob Callen yeah
and that's so I punch down absolutely
with this you know I'm killing boss I'm
doing better and but I want to just do
better than everybody who's that who's
that Ryan what's the average amount of
donation per month five bucks a month I
think so I don't really handle that I
had my people let's smell yeah I mean
all those numbers all 300 page I can't I
couldn't do any you get you guys
somebody has to do it for me I can't do
any of that stuff but I think it's like
last month was like five bucks okay so
you figure three or three three hundred
times five is fifteen hundred bucks
that's like an extra 18 or 20 grand
you're 15 grand whatever it is that can
add up you get you know you get a few
more people you make some real money
doing that
yeah I'm trying what some town makes
like 350 360 yeah but they've been I
guess somebody said they've been doing
it first since they started you know
yeah you also have to do stuff I think
that is just for your I let you feel a
podcast that goes up as well you have to
stop this just for your patreon of
course people yeah but what I'm doing
I'm kind of cheating with that now
because I already do it I already do a
show at come--as
right and then and so what I decided to
do was cuz we did set up the patron
we're gonna do bonus content you know so
then we did a live show at the fat black
at the Comedy Cellar and my blind
sidekick was like drunk and
wasn't it wasn't a great show you know
so I mean he's always drunk to be fair
but he was like he was he you know it
was like well was he a blind fool yeah
it wasn't like highly entertaining so I
thought okay I'm do already don't call
me at once a week and then I got to do
MLC once a week and then I get to do
extra extra because so then I thought
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
have I'm gonna give every other show
free so so too so every other MLC free
so the every like this week we'll do a
mile say that's free and then the next
week you gotta be it that couldn't a is
considered bonus content right now I
don't want to get spent I don't want to
get burnt out like I'm just sitting
there just babbling like an idiot
probably when you do your [ __ ]
wrestling show because I'm looking at
you if I would you know I mean I know
chip sheperson is a massive hit you know
that's what I meant to say this chip is
different the chip is an institution no
I know so I just don't like I don't want
to keep just churning out garbage or
just you know but like I gotta give him
bonus content so I figure just and also
if I don't give a bonus content like
take something away what are they paying
for you know I mean if they get if they
getting MLC for fries you give him the
shitty show that wasn't that good III
guess confusing because I'm like it
should I try harder with a with a bonus
show or because there's less people
listening well though they're already
yeah there's less there's a lot less
people listening but they're already
having to pay for ku Mia yeah but if
they don't pay for ku Mia because some
people don't want to join cumbia because
it's it's more expensive and they don't
want to you know what about a month
it's nine bucks a month like Oh Mia so
I'm thinking like I'm basically
competing Balcom competing against
myself I just wrote there if I give
everything for free if I give MLC for
free why would they sign up for Co Mia
or and then what is the patreon people
getting so I'm like the patreon people
get every show that I do at MLC and if
they don't sign up for patreon they get
every other show or they sign for come
here it gets very confusing like sandy I
know I know it's clear for me but it's
gets confusing people listening you know
and but but you have the same thing with
[ __ ] I mean you guys what I did the
show with date Lando it did like thirty
five thousand hits on YouTube so then
how many people are listening how many
people pay for you know how many people
listen on Sirius and I'm
people wait for YouTube I'd say the
majority listen first not all some will
just watch videos but a lot that's just
an extra thing for people who listen but
like for me like Jim and Sam is Jim and
Sam Sam is a wrestling thing which is
totally different than theirs
chip is totally different from this so
it's easy to separate but it's gets
confusing if you like well I'm doing
this version of that then it's just kind
of confusing yeah I mean the way I look
at it I'm just trying to make money like
I'm talking about the fans you know I
mean okay that's the best way to make
money it's confusing for the fans it's
like it's clear for me because it's I
get it I got to make some money because
I have children and they need confusing
for the fans to figure out what to give
you money for yeah it might might slow
down the income it is but even when they
even when Keith said he's gonna give me
two days a week them fans were like so I
could now I can unsubscribe from patreon
because that's what people I'm like okay
unsubscribe from patreon but it's it's a
$3 signup fee so it's not that much if
you don't like I said if you don't $3 so
maybe should stop listen to podcast so
much and get a second a second job you
know maybe they have the $3.00 but it's
like why would I just give it to him
give a tramatic boy like I'm like the
dumb guy getting nailed by Mike Wallace
[Laughter]
you got me there Mike did say this
during a deposition like like Giuliani
on CNN boy shouting at Chris Cuomo
because Chris Cuomo played an old clip
of him Chris Cuomo played his old clip
Giuliani another one of [ __ ] loves clips
by the way the president must uh answer
a subpoena Yahoo saying that and then he
goes like yeah that's not what you said
before and he's like I don't remember
that and he's like well let me play this
clip that's not fair
Giuliani is like this is what no one
wants to do your show Christmas this is
a just as a complete plus with that is
so funny because the Cuomo's and
Giuliani's they probably all this bad
blood you know because of the New York
politics and everything so watch this so
there's always like bitterness watch
this I never heard of subpoena for the
president's person well you said exactly
that no no and you went on to say Chris
Chris let's distinguish between a
subpoena for documents
p-nut that takes the president out of
the awful Oval Office and puts him in
front of a grand jury or hearing
can't do it can't do it the second you
can do the first well you know present a
distinction before whatever I never
never never occurred to me they would
try out here for a second that's exactly
when you put your arms out and stutter
your [ __ ] that's what I do what I've
been caught cheating Chris Cuomo
everything he's doing right now is
knowing that he's gonna yeah he's like
he you've never said that before he did
that distinction before I just waiting
for him to be like I've never had to
Julie Inez enjoyed a few free meals
hasn't he oh yeah
Julie is like it's not a flattering no
I'm ray he's the body like Paul
Cobblepot he thought he shouldn't be
shouldn't be sitting with his suit
button he really shouldn't no never
never occurred to me they would try to
subpoena the president but that's
exactly what was going on in 1998 but
here's Charlie Rose with you in the
energy you tell me what you come on if
the president is asked to poison you
guys it's not even relevant Cuomo goes
oh and then they cut his mic off while
the clips playing they do but they turn
it right back on as the clip goes on
because they realized Giuliani is having
a meltdown he said we should get this
his asked to testify so peanut he didn't
know that they were live when he's
saying I bet he thought the people were
just listening to the clip and he was
just talking to him I wouldn't be
surprised I mean he should be
experienced enough to knock oh my god I
bet you're 100% right I bet he was just
thinking they're showing this clip and
while they're showing the clip as they
he's chatting
yeah this isn't fair Mike was cut we
know to be fair to politicians and old
people you know they've said a lot of
things and they can't remember
everything that is right no I mean they
they're just losing it so like I just
ran into Nikki Glaser in the hallway and
I'm like what am I said about Nikki
quasar yeah so you get so if you do
enough podcasting politicians talk all
the time and they say all concerts [ __ ]
to get votes or whatever so he's going
to say whatever is a
read at the time was he mayor when he
did that Charlie Rose interviewer just a
prosecutor I think he was mayor 98 right
98 he was mayor yeah could you Marin to
this or he could have just said you know
I was I was incorrect to say that nobody
ever wants to go back and go you know
what I made a mistake I should there was
I don't know why I just don't man I was
wrong at the time or whatever like I was
drunk yeah exactly because they think I
just cheated on my wife in the van well
Charlie Rose's a [ __ ] crazy joke
anyway it should be in an admissible in
court if Charlie Rose isn't asking the
[ __ ] questions she should have
brought that up yeah we all know we know
what Charlie Rose did don't we I mean
he's he was crazy all the [ __ ] he did oh
my god is that what women keep coming
forward and yeah showing his dick yeah
how so detect it showed your dick to a
stranger no I just can't even imagine
you know these guys are so proud of the
fine stranger d-train no before before
I've shown my dick to anybody it has
been well established that my dick would
be a welcome presence I can't imagine
just taking my dick out and go like what
do you think because I'm a dick is not
impressive can you imagine if you had
like somebody helping you out with like
misery loves company or whatever like
it's somebody helping you out with the
podcast an intern and you invited her
over to like help you go through your
tapes or whatever and usually answer the
door naked like what yeah I've never
answered my door naked and you're in
your apartment naked although I put
clothes on even that food guys come ah
[ __ ] the food guy you're naked at your
naked sometimes yes I am like when
you're taking a [ __ ] just Walker you
walk around your house naked
sometimes yeah I try not to the worst I
have a white couch so after I [ __ ] on
where just in case so you don't leave
skid marks I would honestly I've thought
of so you're like a supermodel you're
like a Brazilian supermodel just walking
around naked cuz your body so beautiful
I'm just no I'm so ashamed of it that I
actually close the shades no one can see
my window for mice my Southfield but
what's going on in the apartment it's
it's really weird I walk I literally
would be doing chip in my apartment
alone or a edgar naked yeah wait you
don't walk around naked - no no I don't
I just can't walk to see you walking
around naked
there's something about it that's so fun
like this is
my apartment and I'm just naked in my
house you just psych even at this age
you're like I got my own place I can
walk around I've got a magic Uzi naked
by yourself yeah by myself oh yeah who's
in your apartment yeah well don't you
have to be on your Jacuzzi naked you
could wear a bathing suit no you were
bathing suit how you doing yeah I guess
he'd doing that naked I do I do do it
naked it's outside it's again oh it's
outside it sounds like someone's going
pretty good it's like jacuzzi sounds
like Kevin gets arrested at hotel
resorts don't you go into Jacuzzi no is
talking about isn't is what you do
[Laughter]
Jim's got a nice Jacuzzi on his deck
like on his like you know outdoor space
way up high it's nice you look down at
people you put it puts his penis out
over the ledge I do just hangs it oh
yeah suck at New York yeah
nobody can that's not good you can't do
it on the day cuz people would see you
but I do it at night naked you do yeah
good for you fun just celebrate being
naked who's a friend coming in with me
I'd come
bathing Morna bathing suit I've had my
friends in that's have you also got
naked when you've had your friends in
certain friends no you go to the beach
yeah look at me no I don't really know
you are you comfortable like walking
down the beach which is a bathing suit
on no shirt yeah that's not gonna be me
no you do that you will not be just at
certain points I hate the beach but
there's certain points I would go
without a shirt this is not a point if I
lost maybe seven or eight pounds I go
without a shirt cuz whatever who cares
no I just wanted to be one day just be
one of those guys who just walks down
the beach with a couple other guys and
just walks yes they want anybody to look
at him you know they act like we're just
going for a stroll but they want it you
know they're [ __ ] trolling for a
layman or whatever tiny little swim from
yeah yeah are the hot women I just I
can't even imagine that life were you
just hot I just want to not be looked at
like I want to be able just to people
like I've been decent enough shape but
he's like there's just a guy without a
shirt like I don't know people to go
like look like actually stop in person
ship has a [ __ ] little roll of fat
their trip on the beach yeah no I never
I never really go to the beach but when
I do I don't like wearing shorts my legs
are you're a son of the beach no I can't
I saw I can't even I can't go in the Sun
the very long
it's I can't just a dumb work number no
I get I get skin cancer I've skin cancer
I've all kinds of yeah sorry to hear
that
my brother-in-law died of skin cancer
how old was he he was like my age five
years ago whatever yeah he has red hair
whatever but it's his people how long
how long was he in the Sun he doing out
to her job
now he just I think he golfed a lot and
he just he would got and then he he
didn't I think I don't know I don't want
to make jokes about my brother-in-law I
know but I mean it's and then when I
found it cause skin cancer sometimes it
they find it too late it's basically
harmless if you find it early
anniversary they found it you know it's
already like stage three or whatever
where was it it was on his back and I
think I think your wife is supposed to
check it or whatever so so but you don't
see your back right you can attest to
that you point to the medical school for
a couple of years right
I did yes and so she was skin cancer on
your back you how would you say it
wouldn't be able to yeah hopefully some
guy would tell you no but your wife's
passed along my supposed to look and if
you don't have a good marriage maybe she
keeps a choir maybe she you can't check
your own back you could check it but you
don't see it very well thinking your
brother-in-law's case it was a spot I
think he'd break off a lot in the Sun I
don't know I with no shirt yeah cuz you
know he plays public courses and then
you they don't care if you take your
shirt off I mean look how [ __ ] Brown
Voss is you know I mean I'm golfing so
and that's too much fun he also lays out
though Voss is a layout guy I can't even
imagine that just laying out just laying
out just have that kind of time and I'm
just gonna lay out and get some I don't
get it so he wants he thinks he looks
good he wants to keep himself that color
we get him to take his shirt off every
single time I know I know I'm follow you
on twitter okay and he's got that old
man like
workoutbody that's right like with the
weird - weird titties you know like
they're the stomach too big for the tits
or what he's just like I don't know but
he loves it right let's save that clip
because I'd like to play it for Boston I
mean say okay I got a fucked-up body but
yeah
yeah basically I just want to use that
clip you said that also takes shirt off
again yeah I mean it's just I couldn't
even do that
I couldn't even when table and I was
hair out if I couldn't show my stomach
but I know I had a better stomach than
he did so thanks for doing that by the
way thanks for I don't know for doing
what no I felt like the whole thing was
just like even when I saw say I'm in the
hallway I'm like Sam who you bringing in
today because I assuming a Lenny Marcus
was gonna be here Jimmy Martinez or
something but right but it's me it's me
I have problems with I have issues yeah
that's your thing like don't we did
anything to you yeah I rock you know you
did this are you a Jimmy friends again I
did this to my no I don't see him okay
yeah I just work the clubs you know yeah
he called me a while ago just to say
hello but I haven't seen no not just to
say hello
yeah Jimmy Martinez yeah oh no you
probably wanted something oh geez cuz he
maybe was afraid he that's what he does
what did he caught what did he call you
there I don't want to get Jimmy madami
but what did he just call - [ __ ] - [ __ ]
I think she's oh yeah I just left a
message he calls him my own feet now he
calls me on facebook messenger isn't
what is that oh you can you can call me
if your phone numbers attached to your
facebook well maybe I can just our
Facebook to Facebook I don't know I've
never done it and it's but it's over the
internet search for it's for four
minutes you don't use your calling plan
whatever but it
what's the number Wow what numbers eight
seven seven cars for kids that's right
no but what does he call is he calling
my he's calling my messenger number yeah
yeah - my to touch it yeah it's like on
your phone it's like bringing Facebook
to Facebook correct no but it's so weird
because like I'll have fan like I have
some fans I have like 30 fans that's
cool man like I'll be talking about my
messenger like nothing like
inappropriate they asked me like what do
you think about this thing or they might
ask me a question and then they'll
[ __ ] call me I'm like I can't and
then they go pick up I go I'm not gonna
I can't just talk to a random guy from
Australia you know I mean right it's so
inappropriate because I don't like to
talk I don't I can't I can't do it like
charge them for it that's easy - yeah
yeah that's what I should do talk or
fifty bucks a month god damn it that
would be a good show if if you if you
would give personal advice to people
yeah yeah or listen to their problems
yeah but it's on patreon yeah but they
they just want to talk to me like then
one guy kept cargoes pick up I go
[ __ ]
that's what's so weird about like
Twitter like imagine like back in the
day like the Rolling Stones album came
out and you [ __ ] troll - Mick Jagger
or then you called them right I don't
think Mick Jagger would be checking his
Facebook messages and check out vans no
but you know I mean I you well you could
like - somebody was like I had more than
30 people know somebody just tagged mark
man like I can't get in touch with Marc
Maron right because because he just
won't acknowledge me because he's too
big you know we don't like for how many
years yeah too long that's why I wanted
are you guys friends no okay so so
anyway so somebody tagged him from for
me I didn't ask him to on Twitter right
so he jumped into that because he'll
jump into that like a mess of that like
you to every way does it you know you
get you're looking at your Twitter
somebody tags or something you'll you'll
respond to it so my point is that like
back in a day you could have [ __ ]
right right cos oh no I'm saying you
could be like I want you to troll him on
Twitter no no no it's on the side of the
face dick yeah you were patrolling
Picasso the other day Thanks no but it's
like you can everybody everybody's like
sensitive to criticism so if they say
this show sucks even if you don't know
the guy you'll jump in here defend
yourself I see they didn't say this
here's the amazing thing though yeah you
know it's 2018 you don't have to use
Twitter like if you don't like the
criticism you could just not check your
Twitter yeah but what do you do when
you're taking a [ __ ] that's a great
point
yeah I don't know I don't I'm not I'm
not at that point where I'm not checking
Twitter I'm saying that is you don't
have to I mean a people that don't do
Twitter they're like it's just like I'm
so cool I'm not even doing Twitter you
know maybe they don't want to deal with
what you're talking about yeah but
that's fun I think it's fun it can be
and you don't always have to check at
mansion so you guys like tweeting you
literally can just tweet well you can
just mute people you don't like or you
hug them you can keep everything on that
verified tab what's that I mean are you
verified now oh so you don't know
verified you can actually check in at
mentions and then check all or verify so
I can check at mentions just by you know
like when it comes up if you want to
talk to a better she says oh that's what
I'm saying
it says mentions but right there it says
verify notifications yes it is come and
good people if I just
so it's like being first class yeah yeah
like I'm unverified right now you could
tweet me all day I'd never know because
I just see the verified people I say you
at the end one time and you didn't
respond to me did you yeah
but then again sometimes you'll see
someone's verified you look like too
many people are verified now so they
they kind of they kind of [ __ ] with
that like I see I see people were like
you know five thousand Twitter followers
verified so I don't know what you have
to do to get there it's not being some
kind of a public it's a job that is
somehow public I think and they can they
can verify who you are do you think I
can see their blue bubbles that's all it
matters I responded what did what did I
say well they're nice things I don't
want it would ruin a brand if I said it
ya know is complimentary I said I
apologize yeah I don't want to ruin your
brand really would read off these no I
said like [ __ ] you Sam and I said no
[ __ ] you Kevin no cuz I think what time
I have to be on a show and I never heard
back or something I am jus or something
about something heavy rolling no not
rolling I TMG I don't bring up a source
whatever dmg kind I wish or side that
balls to call you a dirty Jew so I can
did on come--as true but now I asked you
like can i I think you I think Jimmy was
on in Australia or what I don't know
anyway so i DM geo and not in here back
but I go yeah typical show business
[ __ ] where you know I see I see like
having I see Sam and then we're all
friends we I see him at Fox News well
friend dm's not in the thing like every
DM you've ever sent me o up here
five 24 17 is for me here we go he
really do Harbor resentments hey I'm
doing a show on Long Island on June 8th
with Anthony ku Mia and other compound
media comics it's not sold out yet do
you think I could come on your show
before then and plug it I texted rolling
but he's ghosting me
I'll bring doughnuts thanks
that was May 24th and then June 1st
sewing a week later my message back and
said hey dude sorry I didn't get back to
you I reached out to Rowling we will
definitely get you on early next week
you said great thanks we probably had
you on know you know what happened was I
since you go stood me for a week then I
had then I got Keith involved Keith the
cop and oh yeah why that would happen
degree up he reached out to somebody
over here ID rock or something I think
he texted me and then it was done
immediately
we then I was like oh [ __ ] I forgot to
respond to Kevin so anyway because Keith
is like I don't know he's checked the M
so there's times when you just you
forget to check them right and then you
watch him for dick pics I like I get
that but I've heard still in my to first
start doing MLC in my Twitter was
getting more action I was always looking
for just like some inappropriate that
just pits or anything you know all the
[ __ ] you hear about did you get any yeah
dick fix your tips
they were just sent pictures you know
right huh I don't get titties and never
know what are you good you must get
crazy stuff right I get to these antics
in the same picture that's called a
twofer yeah no I don't get anything like
that but you're not looking for it i
know i was i was at kind of asking for
it so you and I said yeah I was like no
cuz we were getting some blenny but get
dick pics and they would send like you
know we called him snatch cheese people
get snatches and then he would say
cheese I I think I invented it's not
cheese that's cool
pulling over the show you still do the
show with Lenny yeah Lana yeah we do the
show occasionally did Lenny have his
baby yet no I don't think so I'm not
sure what it's do you know when I see
Lenny like somewhere at the Comedy
Cellar
oh I won't go in it I didn't realize
there was real hostility what do you
guys down and talked it out you work in
the same club
Lenny's a good guy I mean you guys just
talk we bring Lenny in here to have it
be happy to do that I won't do it he
went to Atlanta is very
non-confrontational but just to hash it
out now you know if there's nothing to
hash out he's like I mean they will
avoid him you don't go in to know cuz i
don't i don't want awkwardness you know
i don't wanna like i don't it's just
and plus everybody likes Lenny and
people don't really like me so then it
becomes like they always kind of take
Lenny side because you sit down with
Lenny and just the go look which we both
got started and this thing didn't work
but I'm doing my thing you're doing your
thing now he's doing his thing like you
should thank Joe for corners podcasts
have you done it I have not been asked
to do it but I'm sure I would like he's
all humble I have not had the pleasure
joke huh where do you get the joke cuz
nobody listens to it go to his Twitter
can somebody go to the four-corners
podcast Twitter he's got 43 followers
Wow it's like a joke but that's what
Lenny wants Lenny wants to be under the
radar
what's the best working why the
four-corners what I mean cuz he does for
career in basketball these type of I
don't even know anyway four corners they
have it's an hour podcast and it's I
don't listen but I've heard on the
street so they do four that's got to be
a different one that's that's four
quarters pike yes but it looks like some
kind of wrestling thing yeah that's not
him it's four at 4pc no see my guest
yeah for seapunk podcast I'll get you or
something like that yeah it's not a lot
of followers 41 I mean that doesn't
really make that's not doesn't say
everything but it says something maybe
they follow lenny on twitter they don't
they don't
okay well then what's it about he's uh
four corners podcast with Neil Potter
and Danny Cohen okay where does not even
in show business he works at a high
school okay a good podcast you know it's
terrible I don't listen what I listen I
listen one Florentine was on it was a
school he's like a guidance counselor he
should [ __ ] you should give Lenny some
advice get out of show business you know
the glaze you could stand at lesser
funny stand that he's faced fine he's a
fine a stand-up everybody's a good
stand-up come on Jimmy some there's some
bad ones there's something like but
Lenny Lenny kills clean like Tom Papa
kills clean this guy's at kill clean
it's not it's hard to do right
does it get podcast yeah I mean it just
tasted new just kickin the couch on no
Lenny's whole thing was uh I want to be
below the radar so it's like okay well
it doesn't pay a lot of bills being
below the radar you know what I mean you
you know make that branding money I am
making money now no no I feel bad but
it's like it's kind of working right I
mean I'm making money a come--as I'm
making money in my patreon so like what
am I supposed to [ __ ] and hang myself
I don't think it's kind of working that
same question in the mirror many times
naked yeah yeah I mean it's pretty
amazing you're making money off the
podcast and the Kumi show and all by the
way stand-up comedy - and comedy - so so
that was it like my sidekick now the
blind he called in last a couple weeks
ago right yeah I apologize
oh yeah he did remember yeah he started
jokes at you they put on my thrill now
he's he's listening very much no but uh
no he's inappropriate but he at least
he's uh he wants to like he's always
saying to me he wants to always come on
this show he always wants to like do
more for Lennie always wanted to do last
so it's like you gotta do more it's like
that's just the way show business is
right of course you gotta wanna do more
yeah I guess Colin Quinn I said I you
know cuz Comic Con has a lot of very
successful friends yeah so I said Colin
or any of your super successful friends
where they ever want were they ever not
ambitious he said no was he insulted
that you didn't ask him that you asked
him I said no I basically you know like
like Samuel Sandler like Sanders doesn't
seem like an aggressive ambitious guy
because his character he's a dope you
know yeah but he in real life he's a
very ambitious guy he said when he went
to a so now he's gonna be bigger than
Eddie Murphy so nobody [ __ ] bought it
but it worked
yeah so you can't go like I mean Sam you
seem like a pretty nice guy but you're
probably always scheming like the Jews
do I'm not Jewish and I don't also I
don't think this guy is the most
offensive thing about that I thought you
just said then you say Jew I thought you
said Jew and I said did you just say Jew
oh I thought you were Jewish that's why
using that Jewish spider I'm a Jew no I
didn't say what are you you just regular
now it's really nice a minute well it
came across as anti-semetic when you
said are you regular or Jew oh you know
what I mean that's anti-semitic
anyway but I mean you got
you gotta have a bit of a plan right
yeah it's kind of just no one's gonna
map [ __ ] out for you I don't think
scheming is the right word but I am very
in I think conniving is no but you
always thinking like not a hunter handed
buck how can I get ahead we evolved
what's the next step you rise yes so you
can't just you can't just I have no
desire to be under the radar yeah if
that's the question right right and
you're you're like just a regular guy
your your radio personality is your
regular guy right you're not a you're
not an ambitious guy but but you got to
be a little I'm [ __ ] even as a
regular personality right well yeah I
mean I think anybody who's successful in
any industry show business or not is in
Bishop's you gotta be a little hungry
yeah you have to be young cuz at some
point you're gonna be there's enough and
for Lenny I think it was enough II I
think he has a rent-controlled apartment
his wife is working he's like he want to
be below the radar and I couldn't
understand that right right but was it
what it was oh it wasn't enough for him
to be like okay you go do your big Holi
no I was right one time one time we were
gonna do your show and I said Lenny can
you do you ain't know you and you're you
and Opie were like it was like it was
like out that you guys were having some
bad blood so we try to keep that a
secret
yeah that must have been a very limited
time friend so I I had heard that things
were not going great and then and then I
hear from Roland can you do the show
tomorrow so I start I want to come in by
myself so I said Lenny can you come in
he goes I have a dentist's appointment
I'm like well you could postpone that
yeah you know I may just fight it so
like it's it's better for the show if we
come in together sure right right and
like in that way it's not awkward
because then it becomes like more people
and to any kind of buzz Lenny is a good
Lenny's a good you know kind of guy to
have around cause he's a good laugher
and her job was to promote a show if
you're like oh yeah I do this podcast
with this guy by the way he would be
here but he's at the dentist teeth are
broken right yeah so he so and I know
you can postpone a dentist appointment
because I came to myself legally you can
do is just a disappointment I post one
over and if you bring a note from from
Opie right then there's no problem
Yeah right everybody knows Opie of
course
I didn't feel I don't even know what to
say I don't want to start trouble
without because I don't get Karl Ruiz my
ass mispronounce his name no no I'm just
just a funny name drop yeah I ain't good
yeah I've heard from Karl multiple times
have you yeah you get right back to them
where you make them wait a week no I get
back you wait til Keith says can you
respond to Carl now it's a good egg
they're all good eggs missing a good egg
Haley's a [ __ ] good egg I've got back
to you since then by the way yeah where
are we friends now or alright I can
swear you are not friends we didn't know
each other well enough but I'd I feel
like ever since I feel like we click I
feel like we get along great no but
after now after the whole I felt bad
after the whole Dave landau thing cuz I
don't know if I'd put you guys in a spot
so then I was just kind of laid low you
know right people I was gonna ask you
out to lunch but then I didn't want to
like push it if I thought maybe like how
you thought I was creepy
I got you so you figured the best thing
you could do is come alone and say I was
gonna ask you out to lunch but I thought
you might think I was creepy that's the
least creepy thing you could do right
right okay no I just I'm not very good
at social situation yeah hard yeah yeah
I'm a little awkward with him till I
manage its we're all the young comics
that come in I tease Jim about it but
all the young comics that come in mark
Normand told us actually that he said
that he and all the young comics think
that Jim hates them which because it's
not crazy yeah because no you know what
it is cuz he don't he doesn't talk right
everyone has told me that but I didn't
realize I came off though because I like
all those guys a lot it's it's sometimes
you don't you think someone might not
like you if they're looking at their
phone for two straight hours
yeah that'll happen no cuz he sits at
the Comedy Cellar table I don't even sit
there anymore because it's too tense but
but he would Immy used to sit there but
I'm we all knew he was busy you know
yeah so sometimes he would be like
looking at his phone and then somebody
would say something he'd be like huh and
they were bye to his phone so I wasn't
busy retracted yes being dirty
here's dirty text yeah yes so so yeah so
then you don't know place if the guy's
bigger than you you
he just doesn't like you you know yeah
but I think all those guys it was just
funny to hear that like wow I guess you
can think somebody doesn't like you when
they really do it good to hear it like
to be like I had no idea that was the
perception yeah I don't I mean mark
Normand is going to tell you the truth
because when you it makes you feel
better like sometimes I think people
don't like me and say not he was just
caught up in their own [ __ ] of their own
moments and has nothing to do with me
and when I heard that I was like nothing
to do with those guys I always say hi
I'm a little socially weird I always
feel like I'm bothering people if I talk
to him like if people are talking they
say I just I don't know them like if
it's Bobby Kelly or Voss you're gonna
get you're gonna talk to you cuz they'll
give you [ __ ] of you on your phone the
whole time
I always feel people don't want to talk
to me like I'm not saying it's about
yeah we yeah that wasn't for a
confirmation okay well you don't even
seem like that's where it would come
from this is a table guys talking it's
like I think I'm too good to talk to
them I'm like well they don't hear from
me they're talking right yeah right
especially if it's all younger guys and
they have their younger guy talk right
the gram accounts and totally totally
talking about Instagram and rap music
and all they're young guys but also like
at the Tommy cellar table it's weird
because there's like a pecking pecking
order like like Louie I've known Louie
for like thirty years you know and he
said and you know but when Louie shows
up now it's like Oh Louise here and at
one time he was enough I told this story
before here but one time he was like
sitting across from me he just sat down
he was sitting across from me and then I
told him the story about how my wife
ordered all Horace and Pete and it cost
$31 it was on my credit card and then it
didn't even come up as far as a Peter
came up as louis c.k like she's
literally giving money to louis c.k and
we don't have that much money he has
tons of money right so I said I said
Louie yeah I told my story he goes yeah
he goes I felt I feel like I have your
money or he made a joke or whatever so
then he was like on his phone and I was
gonna take a picture and then show it to
my wife like look this guy was gonna do
something so he's looking down his phone
then he looks up and as he looks up I
took a picture and and he had glasses on
so it kind of flashed a little bit and
then then like he didn't say anything
but he kind of looked like but I'm like
I can't take your [ __ ] picture yeah
and then like two minutes later he left
so then I said to Hanna 31 no then I
said st I said st you think you think
that bothered him that I took his
picture she goes it didn't help so like
I've done [ __ ] rogue gigs with Louie
like I've known of whatever but that but
it's still like ones once he becomes
better bigger he's a bigger name you got
to worry about with his feeling so
people kind of do that with you a little
but they're like well I don't want to
talk to Jimmy because he's popular he's
a radio show think about it from Louie's
perspective your guy who used to do road
gigs with and now he's like now that I'm
famous yeah now even this guy's taking
my picture but I basically was doing it
as a think like like he would do it like
I would do with a guy I mean you were
sitting there and your name would come
up with a girl or something I would take
your picture it's Kevin's like you were
looking at it like that like Louie who I
know yeah and then Louie's like I can't
even sit here at the Comics table
without someone taking my picture yeah
but here's the beers a good thing about
me anymore I don't take other people saw
I only take my own sides you know I mean
smart so does that's where all the
trouble starts like I should take this
guy's side or that Gus I don't have any
empathy no I used to but I don't have I
just got rid of it because it didn't
serve me now I'm like us just now I'm
just like I can't take his eye
he has my money he's famous he's like
that's the least he can do is [ __ ]
not have an attitude when I take his
picture right am i right
no no yeah no if you told him why you
were doing it like he's he has to worry
about people's motives like I guess
that's one disadvantage when you get
really famous even guys you know a long
time I don't wonder what do they want
motive what do they want and when they
know that you're not asking them for
[ __ ] yeah then then people become more
Sam takes my picture a lot see that
weird whenever we're ready no I love it
I love it
all right you know and then people go
and then you know and then it Louis
started the thing you can't you can't
take my picture right now photos with
fans no cuz everybody wants to take a
picture then after a while it becomes
too much and that and there's kids
issues with his kids and then people
bother yeah kids but then amy schumer
was doing like an all the comics at the
table we're like no they people come
what kind of take your picture amy was
like oh you can't take my pictures
before she was like really famous and
then Todd Barry was doing I was like now
it's allocating of course but
is that uh you know so I I'm still at
that phase where I love people taking my
pictures I trust it sometimes people
come up and they go they go can you they
come up with a camera and then they go
and then they want me to take their
picture you know which is really
offensive humiliating no because you
think they want to take your picture and
then they want you to take their picture
my friends my wife she laughed at me so
hard we were at some like fitness thing
or so like here's a strongman
competition and what were you doing
there
exactly just observing good neither of
those things and and this like father
and son or some kind of family relation
came up to me they're like Oh would you
mind taking a photo and I was like oh
yeah of course made sure and like I was
standing with them and like the wife or
whoever that was there with them was
like had this confused look on her face
and gone like what I'm like handing me
the phone I was like oh and I was really
hoping nobody saw and I just skirted it
around and Jess was right there with her
parents going ha ha she explained to
them what had just happened yeah the
family thought you wanted to take a
picture with him yeah and then he goes
no no he's done he does a radio show so
Pleasant people do like she didn't get
the that I just embarrassed myself and
really overestimated did you were you
embarrassed what she was saying that I
was like what are you yeah you don't
need to here's the thing if you're
explaining to somebody nobody ever goes
like oh people must want his picture
because somebody's explained to them you
know sometimes people want his minute it
doesn't work
known as humility was very humiliated
humiliation without meaning to she
didn't eat she was thought she should be
a nice yeah she was like oh let's all
have fun in this moment and I was like
I'm not having a good time at all so
people when you walked when you go to
the wrestling things everybody knows you
right yeah in real life and when you
walk down the street you don't get
harassed too much right not really
well wait or do when people see you do
they think - they yell chip or do that
what do they do then it really depends
not in public will you walk down
Manhattan streets what do they do
I just got on my way into the what is
this no they know if they want a picture
they'll go hey you have a lot of times I
don't know my name is oh hey I just want
a photo there's a lot more
the people are very comfortable saying
Sami bran muffins they are very
comfortable saying it like literally
when we were in LA some guy just stops
goes
Sammy bran muffins it's like I guess I
have to answer in the affirmative you
know yes that's exactly that's good
though and chip I don't yell chip
because I don't usually because now that
I wear the [ __ ] glasses and wig oh
yeah they don't know a bit of a
different look
i watch old chip videos it feels weird
to me cuz just my face people know that
when Jim is Jimmy's Jim chip he's a
different guy chip has class it's a
different person
right no cuz I I just I look at it this
way the more you recognize the more
money you're making so I want to get
recognized like all the time I'm doing
okay then I get recognized here and
there yeah so that's so Pete you know
like when people go to paparazzi's like
parable mike isn't that a good sign of
you're in show business
yeah can't money no because that means
people want to know about you they're
interested can I tell serious that like
can I give like a like an average amount
of times per day I guess that I get
recognized in public spaces yeah and
maybe you suppose your contract where
our contracts up and I proper so you
only have one year no no's to the end of
- yeah fun fast for two years I'm really
fast but we're gonna work on recycling I
want your money Sam you do yeah well
good luck and I want [ __ ] I'm trying
to get my wife to quit her job but she
has we get health insurance to her right
so it's a [ __ ] health and choice is a
[ __ ] nightmare
you out of pocket no it's a very bad job
oh I guess it's no that's I'm saying
that's why cuz you get it you got it
sorta Union right no no I get through
there as an employee of serious that's
just weird
yeah I have an employee deal I'm not an
impending contractor oh I didn't know
that yeah cuz my wife makes no money but
we get health insurance sewer thing
what's the difference
I'm an independent contractor I don't
know you are I mean I've always been an
employee they just rolled over my
employment
I've always been an independent
contractor I've never been covered by
their insurance like for it for like
health insurance is where you get it
through the union right through like
this radio it's not a union gig no I get
from like from sag-aftra but stuff in
this I wish this was sag AFTRA ya know
that oughta be paying dues I mean you
can try to get my money if you wanted
come gonna huh okay is it harder for you
to get more
money if you're an employee than an
independent contractor that I don't know
I imagine it would be because Hilla guy
a most amazing health insurance and
they're paying for this and that those
employees don't get the other employees
as opposed to depend of contract maybe
maybe my love you worked here now since
2005 is when my internship was 2006 I
was an employee they pay you do they pay
Sam Roberts they pay a corporation no
they paid me as an individual they don't
pay the corporation and your wife
doesn't work no she works what she does
yeah I got a [ __ ] I gotta go yeah try
to get my money no I got to get my wife
to [ __ ] stay home what ya know cuz I
don't want stickin my kids yeah they're
either 20 another five I don't say
donate their ages no I tell you my you
see their ages you know I guess they're
five and nine no I don't want to I don't
know I could spend so much time with
them I'm doing a lot of podcasting keep
like yes at home no do one called
Kevin and the Rugrats yeah that's a good
one no cuz my wife doesn't want anybody
to know anything about my kids so I
can't have him on camera I don't want
him on camera anymore cuz people are
[ __ ] creepy but buddies want her to be
I think a woman should be home with the
children
boy that's a fresh take just started
working five years ago yeah I think a
woman should be at home with the
children instead of rice walking around
Manhattan proud of their coffee pregnant
yeah no but for real like when I lived
in LA I was basically stay-at-home dad
because I wasn't working at all out
there and and my wife had a job and I
would just walk the [ __ ] streets just
killing time my kids and all every woman
that would see my kids would smile not
one guy would notice my kids so it's
like women like kids guys don't you know
I need so women should be with children
and not men
why weren't you working in LA cuz I cuz
I'm I have no talent oh I guess you get
the memo oh you have no talent no I
think you do I think you're very
talented
what stirring up trouble I think you're
gonna fight your fun on the radio you're
good podcaster wait a minute what's
really nice Gomez huh so I'm gonna owe
you and Louis now okay
there was two years ago oh okay I got a
text for somebody I saw I see no III
don't want any Burton Lee I was doing a
I was doing a skanks the other day yeah
so I go I go looking forward to doing
skanks with uh with Louis gomez and big
Jay oakerson and they tag them and then
then I go and the other guy can't
remember his name
[Laughter]
yeah as a joke and then they troll Dave
Smith and I'm like I didn't mean it like
that I'm still making a joke like I
couldn't remember who can't remember
that third guy especially when you're
tweeting you could just [ __ ] look it
up you know okay who could remember the
third guy [ __ ] k-rock when Opie and
Anthony we're on is that right they
could remember the third not interested
not interested you're a baby then how
old were you 20 no I was [ __ ] I was
already a long time into it those
[ __ ] blaming me cuz the ratings
weren't good yeah yeah well so you I
just feel bad I feel like you know now
you are you you've had you've done great
I've done fine find your social skills
you've done great hey I know I really am
[ __ ] Bradley I mean I don't know
social skills I just don't know I don't
want to say good morning to everybody
good morning well you can just say like
hey man morning I do I go hello or like
I go like this like when I walked in the
studio I was like yo dude that was my
greeting free I do that that's my
greeting for Troy a lot yo dude yo dude
yeah but he's a dude look at all the
tats what a good morning that's what
most mornings I go yo dude nice tats
dressed like a male escort who's like a
sailor
[Laughter]
oh yeah Troy knows he sure does I was
like it's always like models wig wasn't
what do you call it when I have Fashion
Week fat it's always how many fashion
weeks are there one I think one a year I
saw a mom know they gotta be more than
it seems like there's always Patrick I
saw a model at the CVS very tall two
year to Fashion Week's but won't they
see once I say that when they go Fashion
Week one at Fashion Week too cuz I
always think I'm losing my mind cuz it's
like it's fashion week again and meaning
another year passed already right now
but I saw a model she had to be a model
and she was with a guy that looked like
him like a the guy was tall and she was
tall and they were like hugging at the
CVS and having like it one of those
things where they're probably going to
get coffee
you like that now it's disgusting you
get a noise like a New York moment where
like I look at all model
he wasn't even attracted a lot of times
models aren't attractive they're just
tall you know what they have a weird
face that he has right they like a
European face like they're like they're
like they're inbred distinct angles to
it like a Picasso [ __ ] nose or
whatever right because sometimes I just
want them to be interesting looking and
not beautiful yeah right a certain body
that clothes just look good on I saw I
always tell when I used to when I sing I
just go up to him I go you're
interesting looking but not good-looking
very interesting looking lady not not
attractive well that would work because
how women are so used to being like just
adulate it upon I know if that's the
right word so if you just say you to say
like you're not hot but you're
interesting then they'll go what does
that mean tell a comic he's not you like
I you were okay I like the other guy
better they're gonna be like what what
you know I don't like that no that's
what I'm saying so but you'll get their
attention cuz everybody everybody going
like that what you're so good right
you're great right Am I Larry to watch
God for if you think I'm good
Godfrey kills you ever get him in here I
wish I got feeling yeah he does he
destroys on stage now he really does
yeah it's not fair
you bring a bag of doughnuts I brought
it no I brought a I had a stop I
actually ran here from so I had to stop
I had to get the bag the dot the
doughnut bag I only bought a couple of
doughnuts I'm like can I get a big bag
Oh like a homeless lady oh so I needed
stuff to carry my keys and so I didn't
want to be whatever you does that make
sense yeah but usually have a backpack
or something no I couldn't bring my
backpack because I was running I ran
can't run with the backpack no it's
heavy what am I [ __ ] Amazing Race
it's easier to run with a Dunkin Donuts
baby you know I ran I picked up the
Dunkin Donuts I see I see cuz I what'd
you do with your stuff that was gonna be
in the backpack but then not but then
you put in the Dunkin Donuts I ran I ran
my keys I ran my phone then I stopped
running I got the big bag so I could put
it in there I see a carry bag but you
don't don't worry about that cuz your
wife handles all that shot me down
I'm so jealous I'm like jealous I'm
jealous I would like anybody who has a
steady job you do it okay though but you
just gotta say hey exactly okay not
great okay but it takes a while you just
get $50 you should see my place nice it
is not in the in the woods in
Westchester yeah
hello even podcasting you have people
two years to have people yeah mm
beginning of 2016 doing good for that
I'm doing real good yeah I'm doing real
good
no I mean considering how many podcasts
are out there how's your tour you doing
the white guys of comedy towards me yeah
one day all right
no but I heard there were some of the
comics on that show that didn't realize
that that's what it was called again
no got pissed I heard Krista Stefano I
didn't know that that's what it was
called he's a car he's get him on the
phone he's a straight-up [ __ ] he says a
[ __ ] yeah he's a total [ __ ] why do you
say that cause he's such a cop he's such
a Frizzle
for so he's such a he can't he can't
he's gotta problems that guy's got
problem what do you mean he's don't like
to pockys doing a podcast with vecchio
yeah and would Quintus or our Qantas
Qantas the guys the Greek guys aim yah
yah he's doing I said I said in white
don't do podcasts he goes I don't know I
go you can't say no to people right he
goes yeah I can't you're doing like
three man oh but I'm not I'm not I'm not
two-timing people I'm not
he started basically the same time he
started Vicky's own so I asked him I go
can you do my show and I type do you
know what it was called oh so then I
said it I said no I didn't say it was
white guys matter he said so all white
guys show III think I didn't tell my
name cuz I don't want to scare him off
okay cuz I know he's kind of cocky you
know so then uh so then he goes he goes
can I when it was the day before he goes
I got spots I got to do this spot can I
do it can I go on first or can I go I go
no I go it's not that kind of show or
not it's not like a spot at the [ __ ]
cellar it's like a show like I want like
people to be there like be into it not
just come in do the spot and leave or
like and I don't want to go on first
anyway because he's not a first comic
he's strong comic is rough right here so
uh so he's like you know I don't know I
go then [ __ ] you I didn't say [ __ ]
yourself I just kinda I was like okay
then I'll just get somebody else
and I loved it I love to say I'll get
somebody else but yet I don't know Nick
Griffin who gives a [ __ ] anyway honey -
no I know but I'm just saying I like
pleasure from saying I'll get somebody
else no cuz I just go show what I really
want to do punish people you know I mean
or at least or at least go like I don't
need you
Yeah right I said it to my wife I'll get
somebody else you leave your wife I'm
just saying I'd like to be in a position
where I like I'll get somebody else
you're not right you're replaceable I
could tell somebody that they are
replaceable
you're replaceable bad guy yeah guys
you're the wrestling fan you're a
wrestling fan
I don't follow wrestling but I know guys
have their persona and then they're real
they're real personality so sometimes
they embellish it for for for the
wrestling ring right but they're doing
it for a TV show like the other
wrestlers aren't all like oh yeah he's
actually a villainous person maybe but
when they cheat to win like everybody
kind of knows what you have to deal with
when you have to deal with comics it's
very it gets very hard yes they they're
like I I can't you know what I mean it
just they get very like finicky like can
I go in first I'm like no you can't they
can't go up first we have [ __ ] Nick
Griffin to go on first he's the first
comic you're not a first comic right I
think goes like I'm running around doing
sports I go I don't give a [ __ ] you
don't care yeah this is a book show
right here and plus it's like and to be
fair to Chris like I like Chris and he's
very good comic he's very good yes but
that's why I want him on the show and I
didn't tell him it's called white guys
matter because I maybe I didn't want to
scare him off and then maybe when he
heard I would if I were on that show I
would probably prefer not not to be on a
show called white guys but how does that
hurt how does that hurt well because
it's it's implies we're an anti black
yeah it's trivializing a fairly big
social issue which is why the black
lives matter oh and I forgot the black
guys matter we all know black guys
matter lies black guys matter who you
Lisa Lampanelli commentary on
another kept getting shy that was it I
remember now but I got shot awhile so I
guess it worked well yeah I mean but
it's - I think it's so a lot of people
see it as an act in progress a little
bit you know but uh
Ehrenberg took it to Canada and became
like a big thing he goes do you mind if
I take a white guys matter up to Canada
I go not at all and then it became a big
thing up there because they don't have
First Amendment rights up there a big
probably mean huh they became a problem
yeah they take out a lot of a lot of
people were picketing and that's what I
wanted here but we didn't have one
picket huh why don't you go without
because I couldn't I wasn't gonna be
here cause I didn't think I was gonna he
would he just why he was going to be up
there anyway he's gonna grab a couple of
you know white male comics in Canada so
people were really what I wanted to
happen here it happened up there where
people were picketing and he without you
yeah it was kind of a lot of Facebook a
lot of Facebook whatever you call it
when Facebook happens sure
yeah when people are like posting and
fighting and all the things I wanted to
hear and it and it happened up there for
Ehrenburg and and then he loved he got a
lot of attention and people were like
said don't go to it and and it sold out
right here to CNN I want to Chris Cuomo
down here going like this is this is
irresponsible and it didn't just fizzle